Hi, this is Taryn from Somerville, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital cash,
the quick and easy way to send money to anyone in the world from anywhere in the
world.
Dash arrives within seconds and transactions are instant secure and optionally
private dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org slash radio lab.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad boom rod and I'm Robert Krulwich today on our program,
stories about stumbling onto the past and finding surprises.
Strange things which brings us to DNA.
DNA is used to track crimes. This we know from police dramas like CSI,
far less glamorously but no less. Interestingly,
historians and geneticists use DNA to go way back in time and answer basic
questions about who we are and where we came from.
And that is an unlikely development if you think.
Yeah. Cause usually when you know, if someone has sex with someone else,
the DNA gets mixed. So the DNA is always changing from one generation to,
it's always getting jumbled up.
One would think it would be hard to keep track of across time. Yeah,
but and here's what you need to know. For our next segment,
there are patches of DNA which don't change.
The y chromosome is the one of these places.
This is the chromosome that men have that women don't have,
and when a father has a son, he gives his son an exact copy. Yeah,
of his y chromosome, sort of like a xerox.
Then when many years later, the boy has a boy of his own
[inaudible]
thing happens an exact copy of the why
on and on and on down the male line. Now,
here's where it gets interesting.
Every so often the cellular xerox makes a mistake and tiny mistake.
Sort of like at work.
When you put the paper on the copier and the copy it spits back out at you has a
little smudge on it, little speck, maybe some dusks got in there. Who knows?
It's not a big deal. I mean you can still read that text,
but this new smudgy copy is in it's way
unique.
It's no longer just to copy because it's got that Spec on it.
[inaudible] this is where the analogy breaks down a bit.
Granted because a paper with the SPEC is not a very interesting thing,
but a y chromosome with a mutation is useful because geneticists can look at
that little speck,
that little mutation on the y and say that right there that came from one man
somewhere in time, it's a clue.
And since they know that little mutation will get copied in [inaudible],
they know that everyone else who shows up with it is descended from that man.
Now this principle,
particularly mutation on the y chromosome comes from an individual back in time.
It brings us to a story that I want to tell you once upon a time a of scientists
led by this guy. Yeah, I am Spencer Wells. I am a population geneticists.
Got into a Land Rover and headed off to Asia on what they call a blood sampling
tour. We set off in April of 90
the 98 on a six month odyssey and it was literally four guys and it wasn't just
four guys. So my name is [inaudible]. I'm an Italian researcher. Yeah,
she uh, flew over for about three weeks.
I joined them in Tuscola and she came with us to Kyrgyzstan [inaudible] taking
samples and I'm on the caucuses time out. It's driving all over centrally.
He said 10 hours in Hong Kong from place to place, sleeping and lighten.
10 we sampled, it was a thousand people. It was really an adventure.
So here's what they do. Each village they'd come do,
they'd find out who was in charge and then they'd sit down with him or her.
Describe the project in simple terms.
Basically make sure that we had permission to do the same thing.
It's kind of an intimate thing they're asking for here,
so they'd have to do a little [inaudible]. Usually a beverage with served,
not alcohol, not coffee,
they kind of milk that comes from horses.
But is it fermented milk?
They couldn't spit it out because they were offering it to me and they were all
smiling, so I really kind of swallowed it and went away before they,
so over this a milky concoction, they'd say to the chief, okay, we're here.
Tell a good story.
The history of your people, your family.
Because by looking closely at the DNA in an ordinary blood sample,
we can discover where your ancestors came from, where they went to,
they conquered who conquered them,
or we can go back hundreds of generations and typically most people would
willingly give us blood samples.
What were they looking for exactly, or I guess what were they?
What do they expect to find? Well,
this same group had done this in Europe and when they did it in Europe,
when they took blood from people, they found lots and lots of very distinct,
separate families with very separate ancestors. That makes sense.
That's what they were expecting to find in Asia, but that's not what they found.
Any case, Spencer,
it gives Tatyana a batch of the DNA samples almost 2017 it goes back to her lab
in London and the goal again was was very kind of open ended.
What are the genetic patterns in Central Asia
that China gets all her DNA,
lays it out and begins to investigate and right away something's a little odd.
Very, very odd.
I really thought we've made a mistake in sample after sample after sample.
He could see a specific mutation.
And when you got everybody that presented that mutation come from one
individual, sometimes in the past,
meaning all those modern Asian guys from was Becca,
Stan and Kazakhstan and Mongolia and China,
people who came from different ancient tribes and should have only the most
distant family connections. Weirdly,
they shared a fairly recent great, great, great, great, great, great,
great grandparent. No one ever see anything like this before. No, never.
She asked for her boss to come here.
I'm Chris Tyler Smith and she showed him the data. As soon as we saw that,
we knew that that couldn't happen by chance. So low.
So the first thing she wanted to know was when did this mysterious person,
when did he live? So using some statistical program,
she plugged the data into a computer program and asked it to count backwards to
the first moment when the mutation peered in the program saying roughly 1000
years, a thousand years ago, give or take 200 years, this person live now.
Now this is interesting.
If you are alive a thousand years ago and you had a son and that son had a son,
so forth, you would have right now about 800 living descendants.
This person,
whoever he was has right now like 16 millions of men.
16 million descendants. Yeah, it's a lot. Yes, absolutely.
[inaudible]
now here's where it gets interesting, Tatyana. I got herself a map. Yeah.
I had the map of the region and I spread on a map.
The frequency of these linens.
She began putting pins where ever she saw heavy concentrations of the mutation
in Mongolia. Put a pin in Mongolian [inaudible], China's eye barrier. Siberia.
Kazakhstan has exten Pakistan and then she stood back and looked at this map.
These pins spread all across Asia and she's like, now wait a second.
So then you had realized that the spread of this lineage was perfectly matching
the spread of the Mongol Empire. As soon as she saw it,
they went to Chris and Tatiana said, I said to him, you know Chris,
I think I found gang discount.
That's pretty interesting.
[inaudible]
I knew just what I, I studied when I was at high school,
so I didn't really know much about it, but she knew the basics.
In the 13th century Gangas Kahn United the tribes of Mongolia into a massive
army and they rode west,
literally killing piles in thousands of men.
So that means removing competitors if you kill him and you're keeping
[inaudible] Molina and then with all those men and their y chromosomes out of
the way, Gingiss forced himself. I mean this, he's the conqueror,
so this is what he gets.
He women having no choice in the matter because that was his privilege in those
days.
He was the one picking up the youngest women and keeping them for himself.
Jingles undoubtedly had a number of quite a number of sexual partners.
We wanted to just be a little careful here. So we called up an expert. Yeah.
My name is Maurice for Sabi,
a professor of Mongolian history from Columbia University and arranged for
breakfast. I've got a couple of scrambled eggs. Yes,
I have read accounts and I don't know how really are where the mangoes would
come in conquer territory and there was a save the pretty ones for the boss kind
of rule. Is that true at all? Yes, that's true.
One story is that he was murdered by one of these women who had sex with their
chief, placed a knife in her vagina and as they were having sex,
he was stabbed and killed. Whether that's true or not,
it's an interesting story.
Well, whatever, if gangas did have the power to command any woman,
he wanted an if the dates were right for history and the places were right
geographically,
all the evidence points in the same direction that looks like a dock and it
walks like a duck. You know, the inference was that it was a dock. This was,
this Kangaskhan is y chromosome lineage.
And so 23 scientists from all over the world together announced in the American
Journal of human genetics that Gangas Kahn was very probably the most successful
biological father in human history and human history. Yes. Which in all of time,
in all of time. And the thing about this story is it really,
really caught people's attention because this is one of those things where you
can actually do something about it. You can take those DNA tests. Yes,
I know the DNA test, the swab your mouth, cheeks. Put it in a vile.
Send them back to these companies.
I may send you big tell you whether you have Gingiss cons, marker.
How much are these tests? How much about not my, I don't know.
It depends on 300 bucks. 300 hundred bucks. That's it. That's it. For 300 bucks.
I can find out if I'm related to gangs cause yeah, I bet I am.
I bet you're not because his conquest routes ended sort of near Lebanon where
my, where my folks are from. [inaudible] come on,
look at suckers like you who were perfect marks for businesses like
yes, we found this restaurant in London. Hello. Welcome. How are you?
The same called shish called go. What? Shish. Yeah.
Shish because for short, for just Kebab,
they announced a major Gingiss con promotion 10 when is had DNA testing done and
Oxford's find out if they were ancestors of Kangaskhan.
This was a very unique and the response was just people came,
there were lines around the block phone call, the phones were ringing all day.
I mean I never thought there would been that interest. I see.
You weren't the only one.
There were a lot of people working under strange illusions like you a lot.
Let me ask you this though, if I, let's,
I had taken the test and came up positive. I am.
So it seems related to gangs con, does that really mean anything definitively?
I mean, is that marker for sure. Gangs, cons, mark, or do we know that in fact,
no,
the only way you ever know for sure that it's anybody's mutation is you got to
go to the body. [inaudible] pluck some DNA from the body,
see if it matches the mutation. So you got to find Gingiss con's body.
Yeah, that would be the ultimate proof.
And by the way, there's a lot of people looking, oh my God. Oh,
found a human skull buried in the [inaudible] barrier.
I have been doing this now for going on two eating the half years and we've dug
up a some very nice fellas so far.
That guy is he cravats his voice you hear is a direct result of screaming for
years. He was a commodities trader in Chicago. Yeah,
I was a warrior of the trading pitch. He got just enough money actually.
He made quite a bit of money to sponsor annual summer trips looking for Gangas
cons corpse. Why is he looking for Ganga Scott Valuables? Great wealth.
Cause he knows that for all the sacking and pillaging that the Mongols did back
in the 12 hundreds cheers this day. Not one vigil dagger,
that one necklace, not one diamond studded Tiara,
which could be identified from the 13th century has ever sugarfish suggesting
that it might be all under the surface of the ground somewhere. Does he?
Just seeing that it all went south with the old man.
So there might be two treasures here.
Here's the physical treasure and the biological treasure.
Well that's what a scientist,
I am a different sort of Genghis Khan man,
but you're not going to be able to do a proper DNA search unless the guy like me
find the tomb, Moises, if there is a treasure,
he will happily hand it over to the Mongolian government.
But damn well officials are a little leery excavation for.
So he continues to plead his case and we excavate her camp.
We at g you must say exactly. Must be a hate into the motherfuckers buffalo.
What do you mean no?
And he keeps digging up bodies always with the same result. Well
it's not shingles con,
it's not [inaudible].
The problem is nobody knows where Gangas Kahn is buried.
They don't even know if he was buried.
They don't even know if there's any place for things.
Define, uh, it appears unlikely.
Professor the savvy says no looking for gangs. This is a, I don't know,
he died in 12,
27 and they had no tradition of tumor culture at that point.
The body was just left word.
So does that mean we'll never know.
There may be a way out of this Gingiss con he had a grandson who bla con,
a famous emperor of China.
COUPLA has the same exact mutation that his grandpa had. That's the nature of
yes, and I think the more likely discovery will be of Coogler cons. Joe,
why not look for coop? Where is [inaudible] comes buddy,
would you get,
well we know the stated in the sources that is somewhere in Mongolia when it is
discovered, uh, it will be a real bonanza. I you talked to Maria around,
I mean it seems to me you can on the funds that you idiot,
you're looking for the wrong guy. Well wait,
I'm going to cut you off. Morris or Sabby is going to say,
I'm looking for the wrong guy. You know it's true.
He happens to Coupla con is the, his, his, his pitch speakers.
He wrote a book on Coupla Con. Okay. Okay.
The point is both gangas and Coupla con have the same genetic markers.
So if you find either one, either one,
we'll do pluck a hair from either guy's body, look up the DNA,
and then you will know for sure if gangas and his family not only conquered the
ancient world but fathered the modern world one day we will know
[inaudible].
And I guess the neat thing about all of these tails is you know,
you think when you're going to tell a story from the past that the sensible
place to go is you go to the library, you go to a fossil, you go to were ruined.
But the truth is you can go anywhere.
The blood coursing through your veins tells you, I have a story for you.
Same with a little bit of garbage that sits next to an ancient shoe.
You plucked a piece of paper and Jesus is talking to you. Literally.
There are clues about the past everywhere,
and if it's a knock on your door and you decide to open the door and take a
look, who knows what you will find it. Who knows where you will go. By the way,
the video clip used in that last segment was provided courtesy of AMD networks.
And for more information on anything you heard this hour, visit our website,
radio lab.org can communicate with us while you're there.
It's here's our address radio lab@wwenyc.org its our email address [inaudible]
album, Ron Robert Crow, which and I are signing off. Thanks for listening.